bill maher says
be very careful with the censorship game
you're playing because it can come back
and bite you in the butt when the
administration changes right so you see
bill maher coming on and some people are
saying well bill maher is becoming too
conservative you know bill maher's
becoming way too conservative he went
out there one time he said look i took
the vaccines i took it and i got coveted
i don't i don't know what to tell you i
i did what i was told to do and i still
got so you kind of start to see
some of that stuff taking place you're
starting to call out the people on the
left just as much as you would typically
call the people on the right yeah he's
saying about that this this past week he
says 30 years ago the reason why
comedians do well making fun of the
right is because that was funny yeah he
says try making fun of pelosi what the
hell are you going to say about polos he
says but today today's left is making it
easy for the right to make fun of the
left he specifically said i haven't
changed i'm still the pot smoking
non-married making fun of everybody
you've changed exactly so the only thing
i'm saying that my point only the only
point i'm making to you is you know
again going back to the fact that the
whistleblower who comes like snowden
remember when he came up with the 30 000
emails and people are like well this is
not cuomo said this is not the right
thing to do yeah you know this is just
not right you don't do that kind of
stuff some of this information doesn't
protect the level of hypocrisy on both
sides against each other when they use
the tactics against each other that's
when the american voter who i believe
james america is run by the 12 of voters
okay not the ones that you know they're
gonna when you're saying identity
identity politics those on one side that
no matter what you tell them they're
gonna vote left those on one side no
matter what you tell them they're gonna
vote right i think america's run by
twelve percent i think you're right that
12 is who we have to win if we win the
12 over and they sit there and say you
know what i don't know if i like those
two stories james it but this one i kind
of have to agree with them well your
your point about leaks i i there's a
part of this book american muckraker i
talk about this this idea of leaks
whistleblowers and and and i think the
the the distinction the qualifiers if
you can see the information yourself so
snowden when he brought those dogs you
could see the documents right you
weren't really relying upon ed snowden's
credibility as a witness the documents
were self-evident
my problem is when the anonymous sources
right say you know people familiar with
the matter
i think i think you have a point source
is familiar with the matter
we don't have any reason to trust the
washington post when they tell us that
we don't know who these people are so i
agree with you if they don't show us the
evidence okay and an analogy i would
draw is when you use an anonymous source
which veritas doesn't really i don't
think i've ever
ever reported something without showing
you the evidence i don't say well you
have to believe me because i say so
when as a journalist when you say you
have to believe me because i say so
you're withdrawing from the atm of your
credibility
but you've got to make deposit sometimes
into the atm deposits evidence
but the new york times and washington
most don't actually give you any
evidence here's an example the trump tax
return story that was a story about a
year and a half ago that was concurrent
to one of our stories that we did the
new york times published a story but
they didn't print one document they
didn't show you any pictures they didn't
show you any evidence they asked you to
believe them because they are the new
york times
when i saw the new york times for
defamation
it came out in court in court documents
in the deposit in the discovery rather
in the in the answer to our defamation
lawsuit it came out that they admitted
they got the facts wrong in the article
and they refused to update their article
that means that right now on the
internet there's an article
it's on wikipedia
facebook uses it as the fact check
that's wrong and they admitted it in
court it's wrong but it has not been
updated now what is that if not
disinformation so when they accused joe
organ of disinformation the new york
times in court saying we got it all
wrong and they haven't fixed the article
which remains on the internet
it's literally an orwellian dystopia
so when they say believe us because
people are familiar with the matter tell
us that this is so
there's no reason for you to believe
them unless you can see it for yourself
so again the rule is and i write about
this book this is i'm creating a rules
for journalism
don't trust the anonymous sources unless
they show you unless they've given you
the actual raw evidence and have a track
record of showing you raw evidence every
once in a while so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]